[Musique]
un tout
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ici à strasbourg c'est parti pour 30
minutes de décryptage de l'actualité
européenne l'europe n'en finit plus de
se déchirer sur la question migratoire
une semaine après l'échec d'un conseil
européen dédié à la réforme du règlement
de dublin
c'est le sort de l'aquarius bateau
affrété par une ong en méditerranée qui
vient en aide aux migrants qui
cristallise les tensions
dès son entrée en fonctions matteo
salvini leader de la ligue et actuel
ministre de l'intérieur italien avait
prévenu les migrants en écoute
l'une des priorités de notre
gouvernement sera de consacrer moins
d'argent et de temps aux immigrants
illégaux les personnes en situation
régulière n'ont rien à craindre
tandis que pour les immigrés clandestins
label'vie c'est fini préparez vous à
faire nos valises
la belle vie c'est fini préparez vous à
faire vos valises et m'ont choqué la
semaine dernière mais il s'avère que
matteo salvini a mis sa menace à
exécution l'aquarius a été l'objet d'un
bras de fer entre les européens ces
derniers jours alors comment on faire en
sorte que l'immigration soit une
question qui ne divise plus à ce point
les européens pour en débattre et le
plaisir de recevoir cécile king et
bonjour je vous êtes députée européenne
vous faites partie du groupe des
socialistes et démocrates vous faites
partie du parti démocrate en italie et
vous êtes ancien ministre de
l'intégration en italie bienvenue à vous
gilles breton bonjour vous êtes député
européen front national vous êtes membre
du groupe europe des nations et des
libertés vous êtes alliée à la ligue de
matteo salvini
bienvenue à vous enfin philippe juvin
vous êtes également député européen donc
les républicains vous êtes porte parole
du groupe l'est républicain dont vous
faites partie du groupe parti populaire
européen
première question c'est s'ils king et
quand on voit que matteo salvini donc a
mis cette menace à exécution la couleur
du ca a été interdite d'accoster en
italie malte n'a pas voulu ils vont se
retrouver à valence en espagne pays qui
a bien accepté en fait de recevoir les
629 migrants est ce que cette menace
finalement n'est pas une manière
de mettre les européens devant leurs
responsabilités eux qui n'ont finalement
jamais des l'italie devant cette poussée
migratoire
je dois commencer par dire que c'est pas
nouveau le discours qui est en train de
faire matteo salvini pour le fait que
l'italie a été abandonnée l'italie a été
laissé seul devant une honte c'est à
dire devant la une responsabilité qui
devait être de l'union européenne ouvre
mais les modalités ne sont pas des mêmes
que ceux qui m'appartient com est un
groupe politique comme idéologie
moi ce que je condamne dans tout ça
c'est vrai vous avez parlé de mettre les
responsabilités de l'europe devant ses
responsabilités
mais la façon de le faire on ne peut pas
le faire sur la peau de 669 personnes
qui sont en danger dans la dans la mer
on ne peut pas le faire en plaçant là la
priorité de sauver les vies humaines
devant tout politique
moi je crois que c'est ça qui a sur
lequel on doit beaucoup travailler
l'europe doit récupérer ses valeurs et
je me demande sur sa où l europe
matthew finnie est en train de parler le
même discours le même langage que
beaucoup de chefs d'états beaucoup de
représentants de gouvernements et
sculpteur sorbonne pour ne pas le nommer
oui victor victor balle c'est celui qui
parle le même langage mais je peux dire
que la france aussi à fermer les
frontières ou donc on ne peut pas dire
moins que ça puisque et il ya des gens
qui parler à des gens qui font quelque
chose que je ne peux pas dire un
publiquement mais en tout de toute façon
tous les états membres ont abandonné à
l'italie l'italie explique selon vous
aussi l'accession au pouvoir aujourd'hui
de la ligue dans cette coalition est en
quelque sorte oui puisqu'ils ont essayé
de parler en utilisant des sentiments et
le fait qu' il ya des gens qui sont en
train de souffrir sur la crise
économique qui a frappé tout le monde
sur des difficultés au niveau social au
niveau de la communauté et donc ils sont
en train de chercher de qui est le
coupable donc tout ça nous rend pas bhl
c'est pas le migrant qui est en train
d'arriver sur le bateau il faut chercher
ses causes autres par gilles lebreton
beaucoup de réactions à cette décision
de matteo salvini de rejeter donc ce
bateau en allant à l'encontre du droit
international le droit de la mer dit que
quand il ya effectivement des gens en
danger
on doit aller débarquer sur le premier
port le plus proche
est ce qu'il ya une forme d'inhumanité
gabriela telle porte parole de la
république en marche disait hier matin
en fait que cette décision était à vomir
non moi je ne dirais pas ça je pense
qu'il faut comprendre ce qu'a voulu
faire matteo salvini il a voulu adresser
un geste symbolique fort à la communauté
internationale et à l'union européenne
nous sommes face à une submersion
migratoire qui va s'amplifier puisque je
rappelle que les réalise quand même vous
oui mais malheureusement quand on voit
les réalités démographiques on peut
prévoir une aggravation l'afrique va
doubler sa population puisqu'on va avoir
deux milliards et demi d'habitants d'ici
alors malheureusement l'afrique connaît
des difficultés économiques et donc on
peut prévoir que beaucoup d'africains
seront tentés de suivre cette voie
migratoire donc il est très important
d'adresser un signe fort aux migrants
potentiels pour leur dire que vous
n'êtes pas les bienvenus
c'est parce que je dis qu'il faut
trouver une autre solution pour venir en
aide à ces populations
la solution ne passe pas par leur venue
en europe parce que nous ne voulons pas
qu y compris quand on est sécurité les
européens veulent garder leur identité
donc ce que veut dire salvini c'est
qu'il faut trouver une autre façon de
traiter le problème mais la véritable
façon de traiter les flux migratoires
c'est justement de les endiguer de
passer des accords avec les états de
départ pour qu'ils les gardent sur place
moyennant bien sûr une aide financière
de notre part et ce n'est pas tout comme
il ya dans le lot quand même des vrais
demandeur d'asile
il faut leur donner la possibilité de
déposer leur asile dans les états de
transit et non pas en europe grâce à des
consulats qui serait chargée de
recueillir leur demande d'asile
si l'on traite la situation si on agira
de façon humaine on traitera à part le
cas des migrants clandestins en fait
dont on ne veut pas qu'ils n'ont
vocation à arriver à aucun titre
et puis d'un autre côté on trouvera une
solution pour traiter les demandes des
véritables demandeurs d'asile philippe
juvin bon la sphère de l'aquarius ne
devrait pas poser de questions c'est
dire si les gens sont en danger il faut
évidemment les protéger
c'est une question élémentaire encore
une fois qu'il ne devrait pas faire de
débat
donc il faut les protéger il faut les
mettre à l'abri il faut les débarquer
dans un endroit sûr d'ailleurs pourquoi
pas en tunisie la tunisie c'est un
endroit qui est sûr maintenant la
question de fond et pourquoi pas à
marseille dans un homme atteint par
endroits sûrs dans un endroit sûr va le
gouvernement français n'a pas accepté
les gouvernements ont réduit pas
accepter qu'ils auraient dû accepte la
question c'est sont ils en danger ou pas
ils le sont là en l'occurrence mais eh
bien il fallait les protéger la côte la
plus proche c'était malte ou l'italie
donc c'est ce que dit le droit
international ça aurait dû être mal tous
les tapis d'accord donc là on n'est pas
ils vont la balance c'est à 1700 km est
ce que la france ne l'est pas on ne
laisse pas les gens mourir en mer c'est
un principe oui la méditerranée est
devenue un cimetière qui profitent
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de gens il
ya un modèle économique du passeur qui
profitent de ce système et il faut le
dénoncer
le vrai sujet il est quoi le vrai sujet
il est avec la france est un pays très
accueillant
nous sommes parmi les pays de ces deux
un des pays qui avons accueilli le plus
de réfugiés
donc quand les italiens nous donne des
leçons je vais leur soit sur les neuf
que la france allait proposer
d'accueillir on en est à peine à 300 oui
enfin donc il ya quand même sur la
relocalisation il ya des efforts à faire
nous sommes le troisième pays de l' ocde
qui accueillons en nombre veut plus que
les états unis plus que la grande
bretagne des réfugiés en situation
irrégulière c'est ça la question
ensuite la question du droit d'asile
objectivement il ya une question qui se
pose c'est l'augmentation considérable
des demandes d'asile qui se fond dans
tous les pays de l'union européenne
il ya une il ya une demande
exponentielle de demande de visa d'asile
je crois qu'en france un dernière il ya
eu 100 mille demandes
il y en a environ 30% qui ont été
acceptés 70% qui ont été refusées donc
les questions que nous devons auxquelles
nous devons répondre c'est premièrement
que fait on avec ceux à qui on a refusé
le droit d'asile veut aujourd'hui il y
invite des politiques on prétend qu'ils
retournent chez eux aurait été une près
en majorité ne retourne pas chez eux
deuxièmement comment fait-on pour faire
en sorte que les hommes et les femmes
qui quitte le continent africain n'est
pas seulement le continent africain en
disant nous ne sommes pas en sécurité
nous n'avons pas les possibilités de
vivre dans un pays qui va se développer
qui assure un avenir à nos enfants
décide demain d'y rester et je pense que
voyons l'aide au développement à mettre
en place avec ont toujours pas philippe
juvin pardon mais je vais reprendre la
question enfin les propos de cécile king
et quand l'italie aujourd'hui en fait se
retrouve dans une position et matteo
salvini là on parle d'
instrumentalisation mai mais l'europe
finalement devant ses responsabilités
ou tout du moins devant ces manquements
est-ce que
l'europe n'a pas failli et est ce que la
france n'a pas failli justement avant
d'en arriver à quai ce qu'il faudrait
faire
la s vous gâtera déjà lorsque nous
sommes le troisième pays de céder eu à
accueillir le nombre le plus important
de réfugiés au monde donc dire que la
france failli c'est faux c'est faux nous
faisons notre part du job
c'est ça la réalité des choses et
maintenant personne n'est dupe dans
cette affaire monsieur salvini qui vient
d'arriver au pouvoir utilise cette
affaire comme un marqueur vis-à-vis de
sa propre population
il n'a que faire des uns des autres et
probablement d'ailleurs des réfugiés sa
question c'est qu'il veut donner des
preuves que ce qu'il fait fonctionne et
il dit je vais faire ce que j'ai dit que
j'allais faire
bon la vraie question maintenant et moi
je m'adresse au président de la
république français c'est qu'il faut que
nous ayons avec les italiens une
attitude qu'il soit pas une attitude
également agressif quand j'entends le
c'est vous qui m'avez fait entendre le
rire est alors la parole de la
république en monarchie prêtre qui tape
le gouvernement italien
c'est pas comme ça qu'on va y arriver
parce que les italiens ont aussi la
possibilité de d'ouvrir des frontières
aujourd'hui l'italie retient des
populations qui ne rêve que de passer en
france 28 c'est un petit calais là
l'italie connaît le même problème que
nous connaissons de calais donc on a
intérêt à bien s'entendre avec les
italiens cécile qui arguaient oui et
c'est à dire que chez choqué quand
j'entends une action symbolique
puisqu'il ya des gens qui sont en train
de mourir est sûre ça je dois être
d'accord avec mon collègue c'est quelque
chose sur lequel on peut même pas
discuté il ya des gens en danger
et moi je suis médecin donc devant des
gens et pas seulement pour le fait que
ce médecin
mais il ya aussi des règles
internationales qui a dix clients quand
il ya quelqu'un en danger il faut le
sauver avant tout politique
et c'est pas demain qu'on va changer il
ya des propositions de courtes moyen et
long terme et on peut travailler sur ça
on doit sécher en des alliés à
l'intérieur du conseil des autres est à
mordre pour arriver à changer tout ça
mais c'est pas avec des actions
symboliques sur la peau des gens qui
sont en train de mourir dans la mer
méditerranée
mais à une autre chose sur lequel je
voulais rebondir c'est sur le fait que
oui on dit que l'italie accueille peu de
personnes mais le problème d'italie et
que l'italie de 2013 jusqu'au jour
accueilli plus de 700 mille personnes et
j'en passe puisque ce sont des gens qui
n'arrivent pas à obtenir le statut de
réfugié de refuge et donc ce que l'on
voit officiellement ce sont des gens qui
ont obtenu le statut de réfugié on
n'arrive pas à raconter toutes les
personnes qui arrivent sur le sol
italien
et c'est pour ça et c'est pour ça je
suis en train de dire il faut qu'on
change dublin lors une personne qui
arrive en italie arrive en europe
alors justement temps transition toute
trouvée on s'est rendu à rome rome donc
capitale italienne à rome il ya des
camps au même titre qu'on a pu les voir
à paris ils ont été démantelés il ya
quelques semaines à paris et dans ces
camps à rome il ya énormément de dubly
n'est dubly nez c'est à dire des exilés
qui se sont rendus dans des pays
d'europe qui ont été renvoyés dans leur
premier pays d'arrivée selon le
règlement de dublin
reportage de fleurât sauvage
[Musique]
il est 19 heures à rome
les touristes se pressent pour capturer
l'instant mais à l'écart des regards
près de 300 personnes squattent sous des
tentes dans la capitale italienne
aucun centre n'existe pour accueillir
les migrants un collectif de citoyens
s'est monté pour leur venir en aide et
roberto en fait partie la police a
évincé les migrants du centre-ville et
les a fait partir en usant de la force
c'était un terrain à moitié abandonnée
sur place il n'y avait pas de médiateur
ni de travailleurs sociaux
donc on a commencé à mettre en place un
collectif citoyen pour aider les
migrants de solidarité au cdh est ici la
caméra n'est pas la bienvenue
la majorité des migrants refuse d'être
filmé quand on arrivera sur le campement
ne vaut discuter d'abord avant de
commencer à filmer
bonjour d'où viens-tu de somalie
[Musique]
dans ce camp beaucoup sont des doubles
inné des migrants qui ont été expulsés
vers l'italie en vertu du règlement de
dublin selon cette règle un demandeur
d'asile doit déposer son dossier dans le
premier pays d'europe où il est entré
moules ou acceptent de nous parler il a
fui l'erythrée en 2003 a tenté sa chance
en grande bretagne puis en suisse
expulsé plusieurs fois vers l'italie car
il y avait laissé ses empreintes
digitales
il a fini par s'installer de guerre
lasse à rome j'ai été sauvée par un
bateau de pêcheurs italiens après quatre
jours d'errance en méditerranée ensuite
la marine italienne nous a emmenés à
lampedusa puis de lampedusa à lecce ils
ont pris mes empreintes digitales au
bout d'un mois mais je ne savais pas les
conséquences que cela allait avoir 100
puis en 2005 de calais je suis entré en
grande bretagne j'y suis resté sept mois
mais j'ai été expulsé en italie à cause
de mes empreintes
je suis resté quelques années ici mais
quand j'ai perdu mon travail j'en ai
cherché un pendant six mois sans en
trouver
alors j'ai décidé de changer de pays
comme on loue à son arrivée la plupart
des migrants double in et ne veulent pas
s'installer en italie
c'était le cas de mohamed pas cela un
jeune somalien qui a débarqué en août
2016 il avait 19 ans il est arrivé en
italie est resté 3 4 mois puis les
parties pour la belgique où vivait sa
soeur qu'il n'avait pas vue depuis cinq
ans mais la police est venue le chercher
et l'a expulsé vers l'italie à cause du
règlement de dublin
il s'est suicidé qui est arrivé à ma
cela arrive à beaucoup de dublin depuis
le camp a été rebaptisé pièce à l'ema
cela il faudrait des l'immigrant à
déposer leur demande d'asile
l'association archie l'hérault soit un
numéro vert a été mis en place
3000 appels ont été reçus l'année
dernière certains provenant directement
des bateaux en méditerranée
est ce qu'ils vous ont expliqué vos
droits
non ils ne l'ont pas fait 10 et des
riches pouvez vous m'expliquer le lien
entre les combats et la perte de vos
terres fin il ya un flux de retour avec
dublin qui est très important l'italie
je pense à l'année passée plus plus des
pubs des princes mille personnes 16000
je crois et
la l'italie il n'y a pas un programme
spécifique et ils essayent dénier tout
le droit à personne qui arrive après
plusieurs années qu'ils sont en france
ou dans les autres pays européenne il
vivre dans la rue parce que la majorité
des gens question double inédit dans la
rue
depuis 2013 près de 600 mille migrants
ont afflué sur les côtes italiennes
mais grâce à des arrangements
controversée de l'ancien gouvernement de
centre gauche avec la libye les arrivées
ont déjà chuté de plus de 75% depuis
l'été 2010 est
mais l'accueil des migrants repose
encore principalement sur les épaules de
l'italie de bird la charge de l'accueil
des migrants repose uniquement sur le
premier pays d'arrivée
ceux ci avaient du sens il ya 15 ans
quand le règlement de dublin a été
adopté c'est cela n'a plus aucun sens
aujourd'hui après la crise migratoire
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement italien auquel mon parti
appartenait à essayer à chaque conseil
européen de faire réviser ce règlement
de dublin pour partager équitablement
cette charge entre les pays européens de
touche est désormais l'arrivée au
pouvoir du mouvement 5 étoiles et de la
ligue rebat les cartes
la coalition a promis la manière forte
avec l'expulsion des cinq cent mille
clandestins actuellement sur le
territoire italien
[Musique]
alors un conseil européen qui s'est
déroulé la semaine dernière à luxembourg
ces soldes est de nouveau par un échec
dans cette réforme de dublin
gillet breton est ce que là on n'ait pas
un peu dans ce quelque chose de kafkaïen
comment est-ce qu'on va réussir à
réformer dublin est ce qu'il faut
typiquement fait faire sauter ce
règlement oui le règlement de dublin ne
n'est plus viable en réalité puisqu'il
fait peser une charge trop lourde sur
les états de premier accueil et donc
notamment sur l'italie qui se trouve en
charge d'une trop grande quantité de
migrants alors c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut changer ce règlement
mais je ne suis pas du tout favorable
aux propositions qui sont faites à
l'heure actuelle et qui ont du mal
d'ailleurs à être adoptés heureusement
position de relocalisation solidarité
mettre ce matin 4 c'est une proposition
de relocalisation obligatoire des
migrants et les migrants sous certaines
conditions auraient le choix d'ailleurs
entre quatre pays d'accueil
alors ça ne marchera pas parce comme l'a
dit l'eurodéputé letton hier monsieur sy
le on sait très bien que les migrants
choisissent toujours les mêmes pays en
réalité veulent pas être localisé par
exemple en lettonie
il y avait un centre d'accueil en
lettonie qui a été désertée par tous les
migrants qu'on a voulu y mettre pour
quelle raison parce que les migrants
sont attirés par les pays qui offrent
selon eux à tort ou à raison des
conditions d'accueil plus favorable marc
c'est là la position de gérard collomb
sur cette question est-ce que selon vous
les migrants benchmark
c'est à dire on peut éviter les maux
polémique mais oui en effet les migrants
et on le ferait peut-être la même choses
à leurs places sont tentés de choisir
les pays qui offrent des conditions
d'accueil les plus favorables
c'est assez normal de leur point de vue
mais nous notre rôle de politique c'est
justement de constater les choses et de
trouver des solutions et pour moi la
solution c'est pas du tout d'adopter ce
règlement dublin 4 qui va dans le
mauvais sens c'est au contraire
d'endiguer les flux migratoires et c'est
ça le message que nous donne salvini et
et encore une fois c'est possible il
suffit de passer des accords avec les
états de départ cela dit moi je ne fais
pas du tout confiance à l'union
européenne pour promouvoir ce genre de
modèle r sont les états qui négocient
cela au cas par cas les états européens
chacun individuellement l'union
européenne
en réalité ne s'en chargera pas parce
que elle est favorable à une politique
accueil des migrants et j'en veux pour
que l'europe est divisée
j'ai vu côté du groupe devise gr d aleph
tisser c'est quand même pas la politique
qui prenait tout à fait reconnaissant de
résister mais du côté de la commission
de bruxelles mais monsieur avramopoulos
a déclaré le commissaire européen
migration absolument le 8 juin 2015 que
il l'objectif c'était d'accueillir 50
millions de migrants à l'horizon 2060
tout est dit il ya d'un côté certains
états dont le groupe de vie grade de
visera que vous l'avez dit qu'ils
veulent résister à cette perspective
qu'une autre politique comme salvini
maintenant et puis vous avez
malheureusement la direction de l'union
européenne symbolisée par avant vos
poules hausse qui veut au contraire
accueillir les frontières mais oui
dramatique
alors philippe juvin theo vrancken donc
le secrétaire d'état belge à ces
questions twittait finlande a dit dans
une déclaration que dublin la région de
dublin était morte
est ce que vous diriez qu'il a raison je
suis d'accord avec lui il ne sert à rien
de s'énerver sur cette réforme de dublin
c'est triste peu me et c'est ainsi je
rappelle que les matières la liste des
flamands on aura pas d'accord
n'aggravera pas d'accord parce que
personne n'est d'accord on traîne et en
fait l'idée qu'on va réformer dublin est
une idée qu'on balade et qui occupe les
gens et pendant ce temps là on ne résout
pas les questions moi je suis très
pessimiste je le regrette mais je suis
très pessimiste
donc qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il ya
plusieurs choses à faire d'abord il faut
renforcer le contrôle aux frontières
donc on a annoncé dix mille personnes
pour frontex en 2027 des
gardes-frontière cependant terre dans
dix ans autrement dit est-ce que vous
rejoignez gilles lebreton sur l'idée en
fait de créer des jeux croix de l'accord
différence d'un seul bouton moi je crois
que l'europe a un jeu un rôle majeur à
jouer majeur et frontex c'est majeur
sauf que ça peut pas être en 2027
c'est immédiatement qu'il le deuxième
point je pense qu'il faut accélérer dans
chaque pays
l'étude des dossiers individuels moi je
suis frappé dans les récents les
demandes d'asile et demande d'asile en
france et 11 mois
onze mois mais au bout de onze mois la
personne dont on a étudié automatisé
ensuite
le retour c'est mon job c'est humain
enfin écoutez vous voyez l'allemagne a
mis en place des procédures extrêmement
rapide il ya le l'asile paquet 2 qui
prévoit une étude dans une quinzaine de
jours
troisièmement moi je crois beaucoup que
durant la durée d'étude du dossier la
rétention administrative est un outil
qu'il faut utiliser qui est prévu par la
directive qui permet jusqu'à 18 mois en
serons en ferme en fête les exilés en
attendant des centres spécifiques à à
enfermer ils sont hébergés dans des
centres spécifiques
la directive européenne ne permet
jusqu'à 18 mois en france on a décidé
que c'était que trois mois et donc en
fait ça ne marche pas on se ne pas aider
brutti je pense quatrièmement que les
accords de réadmission spécifique avec
un certain nombre d'états en particulier
africains sont importants
il y avait un qui avait très bien
fonctionné dans le passé du temps de
nicolas sarkozy président de la
république c'était avec le sénégal
on avait mis en place des accords de
réadmission qui fonctionnait bien puis
dernièrement dernièrement pourquoi les
gens vient-il en europe c'est parce
qu'ils se disent que leurs enfants n'ont
aucun avenir dans un certain nombre de
pays
il ya un vrai une vraie question il ya
l'avenir de l'afrique donc il faut se
poser cette question
et moi je vais vous dire chaque année
l'union européenne dépense 50 milliards
d'euros pour son propre développement
économique bien je pense qu'une
autoroute en moins en pologne ou en août
au portugal ou en france et bien c'est
pas très grave
notre avenir nous aussi continent
européen se joue aussi dans notre
relation est donc dans la politique de
co-développement en afrique massivement
pe massivement et
aider les africains et je pense que
l'union africaine a son mot à jouer
l'impression de l'union africaine se
lave les mains de cette affaire c'est
aussi le problème de l'afrique c'est
qu'ils perdent leur chair vosges où
cécile kengué on voit bien en fait que
la réforme est complètement bloqué est
ce à dire que du coup l'italie est
condamné en fait à gérer seul bon en
quelque sorte je peux répondre sur sa
queue il faut pas baisser les bras on
doit on doit continuer à lutter pour
reformer le règlement de dublin mais à
une chose si vous permettez visionner
sur jusqu'à présent j'entends parler
tout ce qu'on a dit jusqu'à présent on
part de l'idée que l'immigration c'est
ces mauvais c'est en danger et donc
toutes les réponses que nous sommes en
train de donner nous sommes dans cette
logique l'immigration on a bloqué les
frontières on doit fermer les frontières
mais moi j'aimerais que les gens qui
nous écoutent
sauf de cette logique l'immigration
c'est pas un danger il faut qu'on
commence à regarder tous comme
l'immigration
et puis après on peut faire un bilan
l'immigration aussi on commence à
répondre simplement à la question c'est
un danger on arrive à écouter des
réponses sur le fait qu' il fait
refouler les personnes il faut bloquer
les personnes dans la mer il faut les
arrêter il faut les ramener chez eux
mais non il faut changer de paradigme
aujourd'hui que le reconnaître
l'immigration
c'est un phénomène qui ne va pas
s'arrêter avec la fermeture des
frontières
il faut qu'on essaie de donner des
solutions pour mieux gérer l'immigration
une immigration sur une immigration qui
renforce les voies légales une
immigration qui doit être la lutte
contre le trafic des êtres humains une
immigration qui doit être s'investir sur
les causes profondes qui déplace les
personnes alors là je peux dire qu'on
doit chercher des partenaires et les
partenaires on doit on à se confronter
avec eux dans un partenariat win-win il
n'y a pas quelqu'un en gagnant on doit
être au même pied d'égalité
l'afrique est riche l'afrique a beaucoup
de possibilités on doit essayer de faire
voir bientôt la cds et dont la roman à
se développer vous recevoir
oui comment se fait accéder aux
ressources naturelles d'un grand
continent oublié qu'avant que les
personnes arrivent
l'europe a des accès à beaucoup de ses
ressources en afrique puisque en altérer
la barrière beaucoup de choses et a fait
l'objet dans le débat effectivement sur
la manière de
les pays européens qui souhaitent les
ressources en afrique moi je parle en
europe pour dire il faut pas regarder il
faut pas prendre
l'immigration est sabordé à
l'immigration comme un danger comme un
problème non l'émigration ça peut être
aussi une ressource gérer en première
dame en l'isle adam g l'isthme
d'angélisme a d'abord en réalité dans ce
débat il faut être vous avez raison
posez est balancé mais pas d'angélisme
non plus vous voyez bien dans mon pays
bien européennes connaissent ça il ya
chômage en france 10% de chômage de
masse un problème de logement massif des
équilibres sur cinéma avec ali
incroyable déficit démographique il
disait nations qui nous emmène dans la
même direction
et quand on est complètement fauché
puisque je ne vais pas le dernier me
grey qui arrivent jusqu ici pour donner
des forces politiques dans le domaine du
dans le marché du travail en suisse pour
le fait qu'il y a il n'y a pas d'emploi
c'est pas ça amazon.com
je crois qu'on doit essayer de chercher
des traces est assez équilibré c'est une
association qui ne volent pas tenir
attention aux effets pervers de
l'immigration africaine vers l'europe
sur l'afrique elle-même l'afrique
également père à certains moi je suis
comme vous je suis médecin
je suis frappé de voir que dans une
spécialité qui est par exemple
l'anesthésié et bien la quasi-totalité
des anesthésistes d'un pays d'afrique je
ne vais pas citer la quasi totalité ont
quitté ce pays alors qu'il a été formé
là-bas pour venir en france
et puis à part dont on ne peut pas dire
que ça ne pose pas un problème ça pose
un problème majeur et je dis aux
africains qu'ils doivent aussi se
préoccuper de cette affaire parce que
c'est aussi leur affaire la question de
la prochaine je m'excuse c'est pas une
question entre vous et moi mais je dois
erronées sur l'immigration on ne peut
pas considérer que les migrations puis
c'est un problème au déficit
démographique
c'est précisément la position de
monsieur avramopoulos que je condamne la
véritable solution au déficit
démographique connaissent beaucoup
d'états européens en premier lieu
l'allemagne c'est de mener des
politiques natalistes
voilà ce qu'il faut faire cécile king et
vous aurez le mot de la fin en attendant
voit bien donc cette réforme est bloqué
quel pourrait être demain en fait si
vous étiez encore aux affaires
votre réforme de dublin est ce que
l'idée de la relocalisation pour vous
êtes une bonne idée ou pas
où il ya trois points sur lequel il faut
travailler ça se trouve exactement dans
l'art forme de double ans qui a été voté
au maxi au mois de octobre 2010 est le
premier point justement c'est la rue
localisation automatique et obligatoire
et je suis convaincu qu'il faut aider
les états membres à pouvoir se renforcer
sur le plan législatif et dans leur pays
au deuxième point c'est le fait qu' il
faut que les frontières externes de
l'union européenne de via les frontières
pas de l'italie de l'espagne de la grèce
mais de l'union européenne avec un corps
de gardes frontières et centralisée pour
ce qui concerne l'asie et au troisième
fois c'est celui qu'on a introduit
justement dans la réforme
si quelqu'un arrive pas à accueillir les
migrants sur son territoire
il faut essayer de couper aussi l'effort
pour la conditionnalité des extraits
c'est effectivement quelque chose qui a
été mis sur la table notamment par la
france et l'allemagne
et ce sera au menu certainement du
prochain sommet européen est prévu à la
fin du mois merci à vous de nous avoir
éclairé sonorisation compliqué c'est la
fin de cette émission mais pas de
panique vous pouvez la voir en replay un
peu partout sur nos sites
lcp public sénat et rtbf.be bien entendu
la semaine prochaine c'est ahmed tazir
que vous retrouverez à ma place très
belle semaine à tous ciao
[Musique]